hey everyone in this video I'm gonna
show you guys had a programmers Tod key
form all Toyota models for me rav4 your
Tacoma your 4runner just evolved some
opening closing of doors and inserting
and reinserting a key into your ignition
so let's get started so obviously your
immobilizers right there little red
light and when you put in the right key
your master key it goes away so now
we're going to re insert your key out
two three four and then the fifth you
leave it in and then we're going to go
to the door six times one two three four
five and six and then you're gonna pull
out your key and you're going to be in
programming mode after your six door
insert and to know you're in programming
mode you can go your way your
immobilizer would be and now it's just a
solid red light yes there we go solid
red light that means you're good to go
to put in your new key that you just cut
and it should take around sixty seconds
you know when it's starting when the
mobilizer icon flashes in a flash for
about 60 seconds and after that we'll go
blink and then you're done programming
and to do more Keys repeat the process
and here's with my new key that I just
programmed see it's not setting it off
and starting up perfectly if you have
any questions let me know
thank you